Welcome back to the
Pharmacology of the
NSAIDs. This is part 1B,
the second component of
the first video, if I
can put it that way.
We'll be talking
about the class
effects of the NSAIDs.
We'll talk about
pharmacokinetic
properties, mechanisms,
therapeutic
uses, toxicities,
pregnancy and lactation,
and drug interactions.
This chart
divides the drugs
into their
various classes.
You may have noticed
that the class
names are actually
their chemical groups.
They are referred to
in these ways in the
literature and sometimes
in speech. I'm not
going to ask you a
specific question such as,
what chemical class
is ibuprofen in, with
the answer being propionic
acid derivatives.
No, I'm not. I just
want you to get the
general concept here
that these drugs have
different chemical
structures, but they
basically have the same
mechanism of action.
The salicylates,
aspirin, is our
representative.
It's also the
prototype of the
NSAIDs class.
It's been around
in some form or
other, used therapeutically
for thousands
of years by chewing
willow bark.
Or actually a similar
compound has been.
Then we have our
propionic acid
derivatives. You
probably recognize the
names ibuprofen
and naproxen. These
are over-the-counter
products known
as Advil and Aleve
and other names.
We have our acetic acid
derivatives. I have
starred three of the
important ones in
this group. Indomethacin
is the prototype of
the group, so you
should be aware of it.
Tetoralac and
diclofenac have certain
features that are
drug-specific,
and you should be
aware of those.
We have our phenomates,
which I haven't
starred anything.
They're hardly ever
used. I'm not going
to talk about them.
They could appear
in a board exam.
We have our enolic
acid derivatives.
Only meloxicam is
starred because
it is so widely
used. You are
bound to see it.
It's called Mobic.
Celecoxib is a cox-2
selective NSAID. The
others are non-selective,
except for aspirin.
Well, yes, they're
all non-selective.
And they're called
coxibs because
they all have that
suffix. coccib.
And finally, we
have acetaminophen,
which is not an
NSAID because it
doesn't have
any clinically
significant anti
-inflammatory activity.
Okay,
pharmacokinetics. Well,
they're all
weak acids, pKa
somewhere between
three and 5.
These two guys, this guy
turns into a weak acid.
Rapid, complete
absorption, not
affected by food, and
we often recommend
taking the NSAIDs
with food, so
it's good to know
that But that does
not affect the
peak concentration.
The onset of analgesia
is pretty quick, half
an hour to an hour,
depending on the drug.
And the peak
concentration,
the time to peak
is within hours,
reasonable.
Distribution, highly
plasma protein bound,
but they do cross the
blood-brain barrier.
Importantly, they
accumulate in sites
of inflammation,
which is what we want
them to do, and
synovial fluid, because
that's important for
people who have joint
problems, like
rheumatoid arthritis.
Analgesic effects are
related to CNS actions.
Reduced central
sensitization.
Modulation of the
descending pain pathways.
and probably
other interactions
with other
systems as well.
For our purposes,
these are the
two that we want
to remember in
terms of the CNS
actions on pain.
And the accumulation
in the synovial
fluid, as I
mentioned before,
is related to
its efficacy
in patients
with arthritis.
Metabolism.
Well, it's
CYP, basically.
That's your take
-home message, CYPs.
And then the
metabolites get a
glucuronide on it.
What does that mean?
Water-soluble.
So out they go.
It also can mean
enterohepatic
circulation, right?
And excretion.
They go out
through the
glomerular filtration.
anything dissolved
in the plasma.
If it's attached
to the albumin,
it's not going to
go out that way.
And tubular secretion
of the metabolites,
a little bit of
unchanged drug.
What's the half
-life? Well, that's
going to depend
on the drug.
Ibuprofen's got a
shorter half-life.
Aspirin's got a super
short half-life.
Meloxicam's got
a longer half
-life, longer than
10 hours even.
so what does this
mean with regard to
rapid complete
absorption we get rapid
pain relief in terms
of distribution
it accumulates at
the site of action
metabolism excretion
so elimination
well we have to take
care in patients who
have impaired liver
function and severely
impaired kidney function
for several reasons,
not just for
pharmacokinetic reasons.
And then the half-life,
we can choose short,
moderate, or long
durations of action.
Now that needs
to be patient
-specific, and we'll
get to all of those
features in a bit.
So I have a
pharmacokinetics refresher.
I keep talking about
dose-related effects,
particularly with
these NSAIDs. The
lower doses tend to
be effective for pain.
It takes higher doses
for the inflammatory
effect. I mentioned
peak effects.
So here, time
to peak effect.
It's whatever
time that was.
I want to draw your
attention to the
one on the right.
This is obviously an
IV dose. goes up,
and it's in the
therapeutic window for
this amount of time.
Looking now at this
smaller dose, it
goes into the therapeutic
window. It's got
the same half
-life, same rate of
metabolism, but you
notice how short the
duration is compared
to, say the blue one.
That's because it
drops out of the
therapeutic window in a
quicker amount of time
because it doesn't
achieve those peaks.
So that's the basic
concept that I
want you to
remember when I'm
talking about dose
-dependent effects.
Notice these peaks?
They're up in the
adverse effect range and
different patients have
different sensitivities
to the adverse
effects. Some people
maybe they won't get
the adverse effects
till there. Other people
may get the adverse
effects starting here
or somewhere else.
Dose dependent effects.
Okay let's talk
about mechanisms
of There are
three subgroups.
Aspirin is its
own subgroup.
It is the only one,
even though it's a
prototype, the only
one that irreversibly
acetylates a site
within the COX enzyme.
Irreversibly.
So it does not
dissociate.
And cells that
have a nucleus, the
cyclooxygenase needs
to be resynthesized
in order to get
the activity back.
So exactly what
happens, irreversibly
acetylates a serine residue
within the hydrophobic
channel of COX-1. This
is not the site of
action of the arachidonic
acid, but instead
it will block it.
It'll just block the
arachidonic acid entry
into the catalytic
channel so it won't be
able to be metabolized.
And this is called steric
hindrance. It just
gets in the way.
now we have our non
-aspirin NSAIDs and
these in fact are
non-specific or non
-selective NSAIDs NS
NSAIDs non-selective they
non-selective meaning
it hits both COX
-1 and COX-2 so they
They are reversible
inhibitors, COX-1 and
COX-2, and they are
competitive inhibitors,
and they just
block the access of
arachidonic acid to its
site of metabolism,
site of catalysis.
Now that said, we
have to understand
that NSAIDs can
have different
affinities for
the different
cyclooxygenases,
and I'll go
over that in
the next slide.
The selective inhibitor
of COX-2, COX-2
selective inhibitors
are called. So this
is a pretty fairly
bulky molecule, and
it will just get, it
binds into, they call
it this side pocket,
this larger binding
pocket, binds into
a different spot
that COX-2 has, but
COX-1 does not have.
And that does the
same thing. It
just blocks
arachidonic acid
entry into the
catalytic channel.
Steric hindrance again.
I want to draw your
attention to this
box here in the lower
right-hand side.
Additional anti
-inflammatory mechanisms
of NSAIDs that
have been described
in the literature
that are independent
of cyclooxygenase.
So they apparently,
this has been
the observation,
can interfere with
neutrophil activation
and chemotaxis, and
that is also going
to be important
in inhibiting the
inflammatory effect,
the release of mediators
of inflammation from
these white cells.
I mentioned affinity
before, we have
three grids here. On
the left-hand side.
This grid is just
categorizing them into
their different chemical
groups. I mentioned
those before. You
can ignore this one.
Looking at the
one on the left
-hand side, this is
just showing the
plasma half-life
on a log scale.
Diclofenac has a
very short half-life.
Acetaminophen,
short.
And aspirin, short.
Ibuprofen, short. We'll
just skip on down here.
To Celecoxib,
much better and meloxicam
which I also
starred longer.
Do you have to memorize
this? Absolutely not.
I just want you to
get a sense of the
differences in the half
-lives. We want to focus
now on panel B and I
put some stars on the
drugs that are starred so
that you can appreciate
the ratio of COX-1
and COX-2 affinity.
Ketorolac has
greater affinity for
COX-1. I will be
coming back to this
concept when we
get to Ketorolac.
Endomethacin always.
Also, greater
affinity for COX-1.
Here's aspirin.
Now, naproxen,
it's like almost 50-50.
Ibuprofen also.
Acetaminophen, I
don't know if that's
actually accurate
because we don't really
understand totally
the action of
acetaminophen. So you
can ignore that one.
Here's our meloxicam.
Oh, COX-2 mainly.
And here's our
celecoxib, about the
same. The difference
being that meloxicam
has a greater affinity
for COX-2 than
for COX-1, but it
still binds COX-1.
And celecoxib is
COX-2 selective.
And here's our
diclofenac also has a
greater affinity for
COX-2 than COX-1. I
will be coming back
to these concepts.
So, okay, that's a
mechanism. How does
that relate to the
effect? The therapeutic
effects. COX-2
inhibition leads
to the therapeutic
effects, analgesia,
anti-fever, anti
-inflammatory actions.
Now, COX-1
inhibition, we get our
loss of GI
protective effects.
That can lead to
GI irritation,
ulcers, bleeding,
even perforation.
Platelets, inhibition
of the platelets,
that's going to
reduce platelet
aggregation,
which is, in fact,
desirable with
low-dose aspirin.
We'll be coming
back to that.
COX-2 inhibition
in endothelial
cells. Now think
about endothelial
cells. We just talked
about platelets.
Now think about
endothelial cells.
Prostacycline is
the function of
prostacycline, COX-2
-derived prostacycline
in endothelial cells
is to counterbalance
the actions of
thromboxane A2. So
thromboxane A2,
platelet aggregation,
COX-2, prostacyclin,
is platelet
disaggregation and also
inhibition of
platelet aggregation.
That increases the risk.
So, inhibiting
that is going
to increase the risk. So,
back up.
If we inhibit
both of these
functions, that
can increase the
risk of bleeding
and thrombosis.
I'll go into more
detail on that later.
So, COX-1 and COX
-2 in the kidney.
That will decrease renal
blood flow
because, remember,
the PGE2 and PGI2
cause an autoregulatory
vasodilation of the
affarin arteriole.
So we're going to
block that effect.
And also we're
blocking the sodium
and water excretion,
so that's going to
cause sodium and
water reabsorption.
So those are
the mechanism
-effect relationships.
All right. I know
you have the picture
on the PowerPoint,
but see if you can
close your eyes. What
is the common thread
that ties all these
drugs together?
So we have our
prostanoids, our signaling
molecules in many,
many biologic
processes throughout
the body, in
virtually every cell,
and NSAIDs inhibit
the synthesis of
these prostanoids.
So we have our
therapeutic effects,
we have our
toxicities, and we
have effects all
over the body.
Pain,
fever,
inflammation.
So class uses.
Lots of uses. Think
inflammation, think
what's inflamed,
think can we use an
NSAID on it. So
analgesia, antipyretic,
anti-inflammatory,
you know all about
that. Anti-platelet
we talked about
with aspirin only as
a therapeutic use.
So how do we choose
between them then? Well,
they all are about
equal in their ability
to manage pain, fever,
and inflammation.
It's dosed dependently.
So it's really
going to be a matter
of personal
preference. And
what are the goals
of the therapy?
Goals of the therapy.
So, goals and
differentiate
by cost and
adverse effects.
Thinking, remember,
about the differences
between COX-1 and
COX-2 affinities.
Can we put them in
the eye? Yeah, they
come in some topical
ophthalmic drops.
Closure of the
ductus arteriosus
in the *********
neonates. Now,
prostaglandins in the
neonate are responsible
for keeping the ductus
arteriosus patent,
patent ductus
arteriosus, meaning open.
If that gets
closed too soon,
the blood circulation
will flow into the
fetal lungs. And the
fetal lungs are full of
fluid. They don't need
circulation. circulation
so if we that's why
the ductus arteriosus
is present to bypass the
pulmonary circulation
so we really don't
want to be closing that
ductus arteriosus
while the patient is in
utero i mentioned pgd2
niacin is a b vitamin
and taken in high
doses it's used for the
management of elevated
plasma triglycerides.
So one of the
treatments is high-dose
niacin, but it can
cause flushing, and the
flushing is related
to release of PGD2
from the mast cells.
This is not an allergic
reaction. It's not
due to activation of
the mast cells by
antibodies. This is
due strictly to niacin.
So taking aspirin
just before taking
niacin is going to block
that flushing, which
can be annoying.
Is it dangerous? No.
But it sure is annoying.
And then prostaglandin
upregulation disorders.
I'm not going into
detail with those.
It certainly makes
sense if there are
diseases that are
related to prostaglandin
upregulation to use
nansiates to block it.
All right. Check
our knowledge.
How do NSAIDs
inhibit the synthesis
of biologically
active prostanoids?
Well, upstream. They
inhibit the enzymes,
cyclooxygenase 1 and 2.
So if we block those
enzymes, arachidonic
acid is not
converted into its
downstream
prostaglandins.
How does the NSAID's
mechanism of action
relate to the therapeutic
and adverse effects?
Analgesic, anti
-inflammatory, antipyretic
effects are due
to inhibiting the
COX-2-derived prostanoid
synthesis. The
adverse effects are
related to inhibiting
COX-1-derived
prostanoid synthesis.
Why is it helpful to
recognize the affinities
individual NSAIDs
for COX-1 and COX-2.
The less severe GI
adverse effects occur
with some more COX
-2 selective NSAIDs
because the GI
cytoprotective actions are
mediated by the COX-1
derived prostanoids.
Makes so much sense.
So let's talk
toxicities. Honestly,
the story of NSAIDs
is really about
toxicities because there
are serious adverse
effects that
can result from
prostaglandin inhibition.
I will reiterate,
people treat themselves.
And most people
just are not aware of
the potential for the
toxicities or even what
the toxicities are.
So we'll talk about
the gastrointestinal,
cardiovascular,
and renal.
We'll start with the
gastrointestinal.
I put this picture
of a stomach here
so that when you
close your eyes and
remember this
slide, you remember
the gastrointestinal
adverse effects.
NSAID use inhibits
protective and repair
processes. And this can
happen in people who
are otherwise perfectly
healthy if they use
particularly the long
-acting, if they keep
inhibiting prostaglandin
synthesis over time.
Gastric
irritation, peptic
ulcer, GI bleeding,
perforation.
And not just the
stomach, but adverse
effects can occur
throughout the intestinal
tract. So what are
the risk factors?
This is a little
bacterium,
gram-negative bacterium.
Here's a good
picture of it.
It gets into the
gastric area.
It causes mucosal
injury and...
I meant to do this one.
Causes mucosal injury
leading to peptic
ulcer. so anybody who's
got a helicobacter
infection is at risk
for it probably has
a peptic ulcer and
they should not be
getting an NSAID anybody
who's already got
mucosal injury alcohol
consumption alcohol
is hard on the on the
gastric mucosa and
we're adding the NSAID
that increases it.
Concurrent
anticoagulant bleeding.
We're talking about
gastrointestinal adverse
effects and we're
talking about bleeding.
So the NSAID use
can lead to gastric
irritation and peptic
ulcer and bleeding on its
own and now we add an
anticoagulant to the
mix which which also
causes bleeding, and
that can cause a severe
adverse drug event.
And glucocorticoid
use, some
people call
those steroids.
These are used as
anti-inflammatories,
and people sometimes
take both together.
Now, glucocorticoids
on their own are not
going to cause these
effects, but they make
the gastrointestinal
adverse effects of NSAIDs
worse because they
reduce mucosal repair.
Cardiovascular adverse
effects. So we're
thinking about the
vessels, and we're thinking
about thrombus, and
we're thinking about
thrombus traveling to
the coronary arteries
and causing a myocardial
infarction, or
traveling to the CNS
and causing a ******.
And it's these
two functions
that we need to
be focusing on.
COX-1 is present in
platelets. COX-1 in
platelets makes
thromboxane, thromboxane A2.
Thromboxane A2,
as I mentioned
before, and I'm
bears repeating,
causes local platelet
aggregation and
vasoconstriction to
make that platelet plug.
Well, the NSAIDs
are inhibiting that.
So that increases
the risk of bleeding.
Okay, that's obvious.
NSAIDs inhibit the COX
-2-derived prostacyclin
that's in
endothelial cells.
remembering that
prostacycline has the counter
-balancing effect
to the thromboxane.
The body is put
together amazingly.
Now we are blocking this
counter-balancing effect.
Now think about
the, let's just use
the non-selective
NSAIDs as an example.
They circulate in the
blood. They get into
the platelets, they get
into the endothelial
cells, they block the
thromboxane A2 synthesis,
they block the
prostacyclin synthesis.
Now, evidence has shown
that non-selective
NSAIDs and selective COX
-2 inhibitors increase
the risk of thrombus
formation, prothrombotic
effects. Now, why
would this be since
the NSAID reversibly
inhibits in both places?
And it appears that
COX-1 in platelets
is less sensitive to
the NSAID than COX
-2 in the endothelial
cells. Therefore,
the endothelial COX-2
inhibition is greater
than is seen
with the platelet
inhibition. And that
will therefore lead to
the prothrombotic
effects. So we need to
remember, with non
-selective NSAIDs and
selective COX-2
inhibitors and aspirin,
an increased
risk of bleeding.
Now take aspirin away,
NSAIDs, non
-selective NSAIDs,
and selective
COX-2 inhibitors.
This blockage
here, thrombosis,
prothrombotic
effects. When we
think about
thrombotic effects,
I will just go
through it again.
Thrombus in the
vascular system travels
to the heart, the
coronary arteries.
That can lead to
a heart attack, an
acute myocardial
infarction, or a ******.
I have this picture
of activated
platelets because
I like the picture.
This is a red
blood cell here.
These are platelets,
and all of these
things sticking out
of the platelets,
this is activated
so they only stick
out when their
platelets are activated.
These are sticky, they
stick to each other,
they stick to the
red blood cells, etc.
They're called podocytes,
they look like feet.
Okay, cardiovascular
adverse effects
now. Now, I mentioned
this before, this
slide shows basically
what I said.
Bears repeating, I
want you to remember
this, so I'm going
to repeat it.
Aspirin is protective,
cardiovascular
protective effects,
or to say it properly,
prophylactic
cardiovascular effects. So,
low-dose aspirin.
Aspirin is irreversible.
Irreversible. I'm
spelling it wrong.
Inhibition of
platelet COX-1.
Aspirin, therefore,
since the mature platelet
does not have a
nucleus, it does not
replace the cyclooxygenase,
and therefore,
the effect lasts
the life of the
platelet around 8
to 10 days or so.
So what's happening?
Now, we have to
remember, and I'll get
to it in more detail
when I talk about
aspirin. Aspirin has
a very short half
-life, 20 minutes or so.
even less, and it
will bind mainly to
cox-2 and platelets
in the portal system.
Therefore, it's
knocking out the
platelets, the
platelet thromboxane,
and reducing the
aggregation effect.
It has very little
effect at low
doses on endothelial
cox-2 because
it is so rapidly
metabolized.
So that's why aspirin
has protective effects.
Now, the non
-selective NSAIDs have
an increased risk
of thrombosis, and
celecoxib has an
increased risk of
thrombosis at about
the same level.
These drugs travel
around the systemic
circulation. They will
enter platelets, they
will enter endothelial
cells, and I
mentioned before that the
COX-2 is more sensitive
to inhibition,
and therefore that
shifts the balance
towards the platelet
thrombus formation,
particularly in areas of
inflammatory and shear
stress conditions,
inducible. Remember,
that's an
inducible thing.
And with selective
COX-2, they don't
enter, I mean, they
don't block platelet
COX-1. They don't
block COX-1, period.
They only block the
endothelial COX-2
and COX-2 wherever
it happens to be.
So that will certainly
shift the balance
toward the platelet
plug formation.
I laid it out on this
little graph here
just so you could
maybe close your eyes
and be able to
appreciate the effects
easier so let's talk
about the clinical
aspects related
to cardiovascular
risk and I put some
practice points here
I can't say
often enough and
you will hear
me say it often
The NSAIDs
should be used at
the lowest
effective dose for
the shortest
duration possible.
Low dose, short
duration, low
dose, short duration,
to reduce the
risk of these
adverse effects.
COX-2 drugs should
be reserved for those
with high GI risk
because they don't
block the homeostatic
prostaglandins.
So consider
something else.
Okay.
Chronic or repeated
NSAID use increases
the risk of thrombosis.
So let's say a
person takes an
ibuprofen occasionally
for headache. It is
going to be blocking
prostaglandins for
that particular length
of time, which is
a matter of hours.
If they take one dose,
last for an hour,
and out it goes. And we
get the prostaglandins
synthesis back.
It's reversible.
Let's say we
use meloxicam,
which has a 24
-hour half-life.
So once a day
it's suppressing
prostaglandins virtually
all the time so
and if it's used for
a longer duration
of time that certainly
increases the risk
so what are some
risk factors coronary
heart disease so these
people are already
at risk of a heart
attack ******
obviously tobacco
use alcohol use high
blood pressure, high
cholesterol, obesity,
physical inactivity,
unhealthy diets,
they all contribute
to this coronary
heart disease
and ****** risk.
Now I put a U.S.
boxed warning here.
It's called a
black box warning.
All NSAIDs, except aspirin,
are contraindicated
during perioperative
cardiopulmonary
bypass surgery. You
may know it by CABG.
because of the first
of all during this
perioperative period
the patients already
at risk for thrombosis
just from undergoing
the surgery and if
we add NSAIDs to it
then that's going
to further increase
the risk it's it's
really obvious isn't it
okay finally renal
adverse effects have
to talk a little bit
about physiology. I'm
not asking you to
fully understand kidney
function. It's not
necessary. You'll
be able to understand
the effects of the
NSAIDs just with a
little brief overview.
On the right hand
side we see a picture
of the nephron. The
nephron is a functional
unit of the kidney
and there are
there's a million
nephrons in young people's
healthy kidneys. I
mean young adults.
Affarin arteriole is
here. That means the
blood is coming in this
direction. It goes into
the glomerulus where
it gets filtered and
then it comes out
the other side and
we see our peritubular
capillaries
twisting around
the nephron and
anastomosing with
venous system and so on.
The nephron is
divided into
various segments,
proximal, tubule,
loop of Henle,
distal convoluted
tubule, collecting ducts,
so on. You don't have
to know right now
the function of each.
It's not necessary.
In any case, what's
the function? Well,
the afferent and
efferent arteriole are
intended to fine-tune
the blood going in
and out of the glomerulus.
The whole purpose
is to protect this
glomerulus, to
protect the glomerular
filtration pressure.
And the amount of
pressure inside
the glomerulus
will determine
the glomerular
filtration rate.
meaning the plasma
that gets filtered
through this glomerulus
and goes into this
little cup here.
This cup is called
Bowman's capsule, and
then into the nephron.
Okay, so what's
going on with the
prostanoids? They have
autoregulatory effects.
And the PGE2, PGI2,
COX-1 derived,
keep this artery
fairly open.
If they get blocked
the afferent artery
can vasoconstrict. You
can see that right?
Sort of.
Just use your
imagination.
And if it vasoconstricts
that reduces
the pressure in
the glomerulus
which is going to
reduce the GFR.
And in patients who
already have vulnerable
kidneys, they already
have reduced kidney
function. That can
just really lead to
acute kidney injury.
The efferent arteriole
is also important in
glomerular function.
So between the two,
they can control the
pressure within the
glomerulus and now in
the medulla the medullary
part of the kidney
we have our pge2 and
pgi2 it's responsible
for medullary for the
blood flow through
here and for sodium
reabsorption or decreasing
tubular sodium
reabsorption so sodium
excretion and where
Where sodium goes, water
follows, so sodium
and water excretion.
And then PGE2 is
also responsible for
renin release in
patients who are volume
contractive like
dehydrated patients.
So PGI2 has a very
important role there.
So the NSAIDs are just
blocking all
these effects.
And this is a better
picture than my scribbling,
here are the
prostaglandins, and the
point I want to make,
this is the afferent,
this is the efferent.
Now, I mentioned already
angiotensin 2. Angiotensin
2 is a hormone.
And it's powerful
vasoconstrictor.
Vasoconstrictor.
And where did
it come from?
Renin.
So I mentioned
that angiotensin, I
mentioned that the
e-ferrin arteriole
is also involved
in protecting the
glomerulus. the
glomerular function.
So here we have
our prostaglandins
that are keeping the
vessel open. Here
we have angiotensin
2 which is causing
a little vasoconstriction
and that is
supporting our
glomerular function.
On this side, here
our prostaglandins,
our vasoconstrict,
our or prostaglandin
inhibition is leading
to vasoconstriction
of that afferrin
arteriole because the
autoregulatory effect
has been inhibited.
Angiotensin II is still
vasoconstricting
on this side,
and that's going
to increase
glomerular pressure.
But what if we
give an angiotensin
II inhibitor?
Okay, it's like a drug.
So this is a blood
pressure drug. this
now opens up so we got
construction here and
the blood is just flowing
on out here so that's
going to reduce
our glomerular i've
got so many lines here
decrease the gfr and
that could really impact
the kidney function
in patients who are
susceptible so this is
with the angiotensin 2
inhibitor because it
causes this to open up.
Angiotensin 2 is not
present to constrict it.
So I listed it
out here. I want
to draw your
attention to the
bottom blue box.
The takeaway.
This is what you
need to remember. Of
course, you need to
know the mechanisms.
NSAID administration
in patients with
volume-contracted
states and other
states of activation
of the sympatho
-adrenaline, you know
what that is. It's
the increased
sympathetic tone,
which you know causes
vasoconstriction,
or the renin
-angiotensin-aldosterone
system, which is
the acronym is
right here. And as
I said, this allows
angiotensin II,
among other things.
So it's a vasoconstrictor.
Vasoconstrictor,
vasoconstrictor
happens in volume
-contracted states. Well,
we're removing those
autoregulatory effects
of the prostanoids.
That can lead to
a reduction in the
renal blood flow and the
glomerular filtration
rate and acute
injury can result.
I hope I explained
this well.
Disease states leading
to reduced renal
blood flow or renal
vasoconstriction.
So it's two different
ways to the same end.
If the renal
blood flow gets
reduced or there's
vasoconstriction
inside the renal
vasculature.
Either way, it's
going to lead to
compensatory
increases in the
synthesis of these
vasoconstrictors.
And so the prostaglandin
function is to
help regulate that
effect, the autoregulatory
function, which
we're removing.
Okay, what else is
happening? Well, I did
mention that they cross
the blood-brain barrier,
so they can cause
headache, dizziness,
tinnitus, ringing
in the ears.
Some are worse than
others, and again,
this is going to
be dose-dependent.
Skin things can
happen, and very,
very rarely it can
lead to a reduction
in bone marrow cell
production, and
thrombocytopenia,
so low platelets,
aplastic anemia, meaning
everything gets
suppressed.
Agranulocytosis means the
neutrophils
get suppressed.
So why do we
care? I put this
evidence down here.
This is from 2006.
It is still
relevant today.
It hasn't changed
since then.
So what's our
practice point?
A thorough
patient evaluation
to identify for
risk factors.
GI, cardiovascular, acute
kidney injury,
and others.
And by so doing,
along with the lowest
possible dose, the
lowest effective
dose, for the
shortest duration of
time possible to
manage whatever it is
we're managing can
reduce the risk.
Knowledge check time.
How does NSAID
use increase
the risk of bleeding?
Inhibiting COX-1-derived
rhaboxane A2 synthesis
in platelets reduces
platelet aggregation
and local
vasoconstriction, basically
reducing the formation
of the platelet plug.
how does oh this should
be a question how
does use of non
-selective NSAIDs and
COX-2 selective drugs
increase the risk
of myocardial infarction
and ****** well
this is the thrombogenic
component by
inhibiting the
counterbalancing effects of
endothelial COX-2
derived prostacycline
and non-selective NSAIDs
inhibit both of those
functions but the
COX-2 side appears to
be more sensitive to
block and therefore we
get this shift over
to the platelet plug
formation side and that
can lead to thrombus
formation which can lead
to myocardial infarction
or ****** and that's
the cardiovascular
risk adverse events that
we're talking about.
What organ system is
most frequently injured
by NSAID use? Okay,
think now. Most
frequently injured.
Maybe you didn't get that
point. You kind of
got lost in all these
other toxicities. I could
certainly understand
that, which is why I
made this question.
All right, you
have an answer?
The GI system. this
can happen in lots of
people even previously
healthy people so
it's all related to the
dose and the duration
of use by inhibiting
the cytoprotective
cox-1 derived pge2
and prostacycline we
therefore inhibit
secretion of mucus and
bicarbonate, we
inhibit that effects on
blood flow, maintenance
of the blood flow,
and we inhibit the
acid reducing effects.
And don't forget,
please, NSAIDs
also reduce repair
mechanisms and
increase the
risk of bleeding.
Which NSAID subclass
has a dose-dependent
lower risk of GI
adverse effects.
All right now we have
to go think back to
affinities. Think
back to affinities.
So what are the selective
COX-2 NSAIDs known for?
Reduced GI effects.
So COX-2 selective
agents do not inhibit
COX-1 mediated
cytoprotective effects. The
NSAIDs that have a
greater affinity for
COX2 tend to have a
lower affinity for these
GI adverse effects.
And this is dose
related. The higher
the dose, we lose that.
Chronic or repeated NSAID
use can lead to
acute injury.
By how?
By inhibiting the
autoregulatory
vasodilation of the
afferent arteriole
by PGE2 and PGI2.
And that will
reduce renal
perfusion, renal blood
flow, and glomerular
filtration rate.
Patients with volume
depletion, chronic
kidney disease, heart
failure, cirrhosis,
or in states of
sympassoadrenal or
renal. In other
words, these people
have high tone of their
sympathetic nervous
system trying to
overcome the effects
of these disorders,
these diseases.
In addition,
the renin-angiotensin
-aldosterone system
is activated.
And therefore, there's
a high risk of acute
kidney injury in
these patients when
they receive NSAIDs,
especially regularly.
And cardiovascular
adverse effects? Well,
that's all about the
thromboxane A2, the shift
towards the platelet
plug and away from
the counterbalancing
effects. And I do want to
also remind you, I
forgot to mention it
somewhere, I will be
bringing it back though,
hyperkalemia is an
adverse effect of the
NSAIDs and it's related
to renal function
and therefore high
potassium levels in
the blood, there's a
risk of arrhythmia.
Pregnancy and
lactation. Okay,
what can we use?
Should we use?
Please know this.
We always want to
know if the drugs that
we use are safe in the
pregnant individual.
So I'll bring your
attention here.
First trimester,
they're not strongly
associated with birth
defects. There's
conflicting
opinions. The general
consensus is they
shouldn't be used even
in the first trimester
if avoidable.
Going back to the top,
beginning 20 weeks of
gestation and
throughout. Okay.
Now, I'm just going
to talk to you.
During pregnancy,
as the fetus grows,
the quantity of
amniotic fluid
increases in order
to cushion the fetus.
And amniotic fluid
comes from the
fetus's urine.
It's from baby pee.
And what is a
requirement for the
fetus to be urinating
is functional
kidneys. Well, we
know that NSAIDs
have adverse
effects on kidneys,
even fetal kidneys.
So if there's fetal
renal dysfunction
because of the
maternal use of
NSAIDs, That's going to
reduce the amount
of concentration of
amniotic fluid that's
being produced by
the fetus. And that's
the oligo part.
Oligo means too little.
So too little amniotic
fluid is produced.
And that loses all of
the cushioning effects
that amniotic fluid is
there for. And if the
injury to the kidney
is bad enough, the
impairment is bad enough,
the fetus could die.
So really they should
be avoided, especially
regular use,
beginning 20 weeks of
gestation in order to
not damage the fetal
kidneys and reduce
the amount of amniotic
fluid that's being
produced. Now, after
30 weeks gestation,
I referred to the
patent ductus arteriosus
before, which is
that structure that
causes blood to bypass
the pulmonary
circulation. All right,
from about 30 weeks
gestation, if maternal
use of NSAIDs is
regular maternal use
over a certain
period of time, and
honestly, this can be
seen even in two days,
the ductus arteriosus
could close.
I mean, yeah,
could close because
it's prostaglandins
that keep it
open, so we don't
want to block them.
But if the ductus
arteriosus is closed,
then that will shift
the circulation
to the pulmonary
circulation.
That can cause
pulmonary hypertension,
right-sided heart
failure, ascites,
and pleural
effusion of the
fetus. That's called
fetal hydrops.
For a long time,
low-dose aspirin was
also included in this
group. So it has been
studied since then
because sometimes the
pregnant individual is
going to need the
cardiovascular protective
effects of low-dose
aspirin. So the
recommendation now is
that low-dose aspirin may
not be as likely to
cause these effects.
It's always a risk
-benefit. You have to
talk to the patient
about it and decide
together on how to
handle the issues.
Okay, let's talk drug
interactions now. We'll
begin. Remember,
drug interactions are
not only drug-drug
interactions. They're drug
-disease interactions,
drug-food interactions,
drug-herbal interactions.
So here we'll
talk about drug-disease
interactions. So,
that means if an NSAID
is given, how can it
exacerbate a particular
disease state? Well,
NSAIDs, I put elderly
here, not that
elderliness is a
disease, most certainly
not. Being an older
individual is a great
time of life,
especially when healthy.
But many elderly people
have comorbidities.
They have
differences in their
pharmacokinetic
properties,
lower muscle
mass, on and on.
So we need to be
thinking about how
to dose these if
the elderly person
should get them in
the first place.
Patients with
cardiovascular risk,
obviously hypertension,
fluid retention,
heart failure, all
goes right back to the
cardiovascular effects
of these drugs.
Coagulation disorder.
Ulcer.
Bleeding.
Hepatic or renal
impairment.
And now I put
contraindications. Asthma.
And we'll talk about
that with aspirin.
Coronary artery bypass
graft. I mentioned
that before. It's a
black box warning.
Bariatric surgery.
They already
have reduced
mucosal defenses.
Pregnancy we mentioned.
And, of course,
whenever a patient has
an allergic reaction to
a drug, it should be
avoided in the future.
Some drug-drug
interactions. And
I put the mechanisms
in the following
slides for,
well, for most of
these. I'll come
back to this one.
But diuretics.
Diuretics,
prostaglandins,
prostanoids are
involved with
diuretic therapy.
Diuretics increase
the excretion of
sodium and water.
And what do the prostanoids
do? They increase
the excretion of sodium
and water. So they
work together. And
we are blocking that
effect. So on top of
blocking the cooperative
effect with the diuretics,
we're also increasing
sodium and water
retention, and that can
increase blood pressure.
So, using an NSAID
in a person who's
taking antihypertensive
drugs can blunt the
antihypertensive effect.
Anticoagulants
bleeding, obviously,
antiplatelet
drugs bleeding,
drugs that cause
mucosal injury,
more mucosal injury.
I'll take a moment here
to talk about these.
selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors so
they they block the
serotonin reuptake
protein transporter
okay well what's that
got to do with
platelets well platelets
also take up serotonin
and serotonin is
released at the same
time as thromboxane when
the platelet is
activated, and serotonin
is also involved in
platelet aggregation.
And how is it taken
up into the platelet?
Well, it doesn't start
out there. It's taken
up by the serotonin
reuptake transporter.
So if we block the
transporter, then
the The serotonin
is not reaching
the inside of
the platelet, and
therefore there's
decreased concentration
of serotonin inside
the platelet.
So there will
be less released
upon activation,
and that can
increase the
risk of bleeding.
Lithium, I'm
not going into.
That's a drug that's
just got a very narrow
therapeutic window.
it's a little ion
and a lot of things
can affect its levels
that's a lecture
for another day okay
let's talk about the
renin angiotensin
inhibitors they're
called RAS inhibitors I
listed them out here
I have a this is a
co-pilot generated
picture of a glomerulus
with the afarin and
eferrin arteriole.
We know that
NSAIDs block the
vasodilatory effects,
so that can cause
vasoconstriction.
And we know that the
RAS inhibitors block
the vasoconstrictive
effect. So what's
going on? Less blood
is going in here,
less blood is going
through the glomerulus,
and it's not being
the pressure from
the vasoconstriction
by the angiotensin
2 is not protecting
the glomerulus, so
the GFR goes down.
And decreased
glomerular pressure
may cause acute
kidney injury
in the vulnerable
patient.
Now,
this is getting
to the potassium.
Potassium.
NSAIDs cause increased
potassium reabsorption.
It's just one of the
things it does. It's
related to all its
kidney effects. I'm
not going into the
mechanism. You don't have
to know it now. I
hate to ask you to
memorize something,
but just remember this.
So NSAIDs increase
potassium reabsorption.
RAS inhibitors increase
Oh, goodness, take
them both together.
Besides this effect on
renal blood flow, we
get the increase in
potassium in the blood.
And what does
increased serum
potassium hyperkalemia
lead to? It
can lead to
cardiac arrhythmia.
And we talked
about sodium and
water reabsorption
a bunch of times.
Okay,
those are the mechanisms
of the adverse
effects of the
drug interactions.
And these are the
diuretics that I talked
about, antihypertensives,
these drugs
that increase
bleeding on their own.
drugs that cause
injury to intestinal
mucosa, selective
serotonin
inhibitor that I
mentioned, lithium,
and let's check
our knowledge.
How does maternal chronic
NSAID use affect
the fetus?
Oligohydramnios,
enclosure of the patent
ductus arteriosus.
So oligohydramnios,
we want to avoid
NSAID use from 20
weeks onward, and
closure of the PDA
we want to avoid
from 30 weeks onward.
So basically,
don't take NSAIDs.
And sum up the
mechanisms of the
drug interactions
in two sentences.
Current use of drugs
that have the same
effects, therapeutic
or adverse, enhance
the NSAIDs related
adverse effects.
GI irritants, drugs
that increase bleeding,
drugs that modify
blood pressure, renal
perfusion, drugs with
CNS side effects.
Drugs that modify
clearance of NSAIDs,
and NSAIDs that
modify clearance of
other drugs. That's
it in a nutshell.
So, here's a summary.
This is the arachidonic
acid to the
cyclooxygenase, to the
prostanoid pathway
if this helps you and
I put here the NSAID
class effects and
just bulleted hopefully
it's it's easy to
see and brief adverse
effects and some
more adverse effects
and here the check
your knowledge
questions and with the
answers revealed and
please be careful with
your prescribing.
The lowest effective
dose for the shortest
duration possible,
patient-centered, safe,
effective, and necessary.
Thank you. That ends
part one of the NSAIDs.